it was a historic moment back on the 7th
of june last year when the edward
colston statue as you say was toppled
around about 500 meters or so from
the museum where it's now on display you
can just see
the harbor in the background here that
is where it was chucked into the water
by those protesters during that black
lives matter protest
uh on the 7th of june it was recovered a
couple of nights later by the council
and what's been happening over the last
12 months
they've not been restoring it they've
been conserving it so it's gone on
display today at the m shed museum
here in bristol you'll still see the
graffiti on it you'll still see some of
the writing on the statue the scratches
uh the carlson's actually lost its cane
and a part of its coat was chipped off
when it was chucked into
the harbor there by the protesters and
it's been put in the
museum behind us here lying on its side
there was a
a moral discussion and a decision made
by the history commission here in
bristol and
the m shed not to erect the statue again
in an upright position instead have it
lying on its side and as you say
surrounded by the placards and some
contextual information
in the museum about just what happened
one year ago today well tickets
have sold out for today and indeed this
weekend to come to the m
shed but we've been catching up with
some of those people who've been managed
to
imagine getting today and take a look
and hear their thoughts
about seeing the costume statue one year
on
to me that isn't the correct place for
it to be
um rather than sort of being looked at
as something really
you know uh great to see it was good to
explain to the children
what it was all about and for them to
understand
why it was important not to destroy the
statue but still to display it
in a museum so people could could be
aware of the history of it really
it represents what we've been through
in the in the past and then what we've
been through
obviously last year as well with um
george floyd on that
so it yeah i think it's a perfect place
for it because otherwise it
i don't i don't think it should be back
on its plymouth anyway
thoughts there from some of the uh
people from bristol who've managed to
get tickets to the m shed today this is
not the final place for the colston
statue
as long as well as the statue going on
display today there is a survey which is
open to the public to find out exactly
what bristolians want to do
with not only the statue are in the m
shed here but also the empty plinth that
of course has been empty since
it was toppled a year ago just behind
the bridge here behind me that plinth
remains the future of the the future of
the statue will
be decided from a consultation there's
no deadline on that there's no deadline
as to how long the temporary exhibition
at the m shed here will go on for we
expect it to go on for
until at least the end of this year as
well as that survey and then a final
decision will be made
as to where that cost and statue and the
context behind it
will be put on display and we'll wait to
see that set probably next year but
for now this exhibition has opened and
as i say the tickets sold out
for this weekend so far